Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here's a caller who wants to know, are
Democrats abandoning the Democratic
Party because of woke? Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Hey, David Pakman or Park,
man? First time caller wanting to ask
you about the left, and I wanted you to
speak on people kind of leaving the left and
turning away from the party because it's becoming
a little bit too woke. An example of
maybe what Bill Maher was saying where,
you know, most Democrats, classic Democrats
are staying as the party is moving along.
Appreciate it, big fan. Thanks.
David postman or Postman Pass?
Thanks.
Speaker 1: Mm hmm. Yeah. Very,
very much struggling with my name. So, listen,
this is just a question of party registration.
If we look at the party registration trend
going back to 2004, which is eight years,
you see a similar percentage of the country
registered as Democrats. It really hasn't moved
very much. Right after Barack Obama won in 2008,
you saw a little bit of a spike in the number of
Americans who were registered as Democrats. And
then you saw it settle back down again. But it's
basically been extraordinarily stable for at least
eight years. So when all you know, there's all
these movements that claim all of these people
are abandoning the Democratic Party. There was
the so-called the black sit movement, black exit
of black people leaving the Democratic Party.
It's not actually shown in the data. The
Democratic Party registration is very stable.
Black folks still overwhelmingly voting for
Democrats. The claim that the Democratic
Party is being abandoned because of supposed
wokeism. It's not showing up in any data.
And so that's what I go by my opinion or whether
I personally know someone that has left or
joined the Democratic Party, it doesn't really
matter. What matters is what does the data show?
The data doesn't show that people are abandoning
the Democratic Party. We have a great bonus show
for you today. An appeals court finds Florida's
new social media law unconstitutional. The
Supreme Court makes it tougher for inmates
to win release from prison because of bad
lawyering they say they've received. And
lastly, Starbucks is completely exiting Russia,
joining McDonald's, some McDonald's and a
bunch of other brands. All of those stories
and more on today's bonus show. Sign up and
join Pacman dot com to get instant access.